[Musique]
me dis juste à la fin du ii le soleil
vous
tu es
j'ai de la france et le
vaincus l'on utilise assez chaud c'est
cette énergie comme une autre et la
chaleur qui règne ici
aussi d'inergy perdu 1 priori si on la
récupère pas le choix qu'on la récupère
non d'accord fo condamne ou encore i té
maximum et pas tous cas un mois de
chaleurs dans les fentes alger par
antenne de la cia a
koné légionnaires qui venait du sahara
il avait bien fait trois guerres ou la
même je sais pas il s'est cru malène
fauchère il est sorti comme ça et depuis
pauvre misère
il est devenu sadate le solaire c'est
chez les filles atteintes niort avons eu
zéro le soleil
enfin chez les filles ne sortait pas un
jeu à pau connais pas la chaleur
pas spécialement quand ceux qui
souffriraient la chaleur est ce que vous
avez un remède ou un conseil à leur
donner la bosse de flotte
[Rires]
non non c'est chez les filles attention
avant nos jours le soleil
c'est chaud les filles nos sortait
passage à pau
[Musique]